tell me a story tell you a story how are
you a story like a made-up story does it
have to be a made-up story
what kind of story any story a story
about what anything you want I think
what I'm going to tell you is about this
time I lived in Cameroon Africa at the
time and I needed a ride and so I was
hitchhiking in Cameroon Africa and I got
in this truck and it seemed fine the
guys were cool whatever and we were
driving down this long road and all
sudden I felt these like big pushes from
behind the scene and it was like a
pickup truck that was covered and I was
like oh that seems weird the road must
be really bumpy and I kept happening and
kept happening finally I was like is
there something in the bed of the truck
and they were like oh yeah it's this
bowl that's in the bed of the truck that
was drugged but may not be drugged for
long so we really need to get you where
you're going as fast as possible so for
the rest of the ride I just kept getting
any strong kicks through the truck that
were from this bull that was in the
as a truck but we made it so it was
awesome and it was an adventure that's
my story I used to imagine when I was a
kid
that my mother paid people to be my
friends sort of like The Truman Show but
in that it was just my mother who was
sort of orchestrating it
the gentleman that I'm here with today
is my boyfriend and we went to a wedding
yesterday and I took some pictures that
les and I mentioned how he looks a
little different in the pictures he's
like yeah I'm getting older but in my
mind in my overactive imagination I just
sort of imagined hope that he has a twin
and that my mother has paid both him and
the twin to be in my life so yeah that's
just my overactive imagination there's
your story I guess there's no real good
end my mother paid you as well all right
once there was a little boy who was
pretty scared of everything and when
that boy grew up he was still pretty
scared of everything
and you realize that you wouldn't be
able to do what you wanted in life if
you didn't face his fears and that
little boy jumped out of a plane and it
helped him greatly I know a couple of
the men here in San Diego
the now husband it was from Central
America the wife was from here and with
a med that was in a couple weeks he'll
go back to his country because to
Namibia and so the girl was left here
alone trying to decide like if she was
going to stay and just continue to work
and do her job and forget about him or
leave everything else find and fly to
another country to go live with him
which is what she did
that's it now they're happily married
and they have two kids good friend of
yours no this is me when I was a
teenager
oh I got a job and they know I got this
girl that I live in like I invite her to
different places but she always say no
and no and once she decide to go out
with me
we went through some Chinese food and we
got a fortune cookie and I'm her cookie
said the true love is next to you so
after that we started going off and she
become my girlfriend so I was diving off
the coast of Hawaii about ten years ago
and I was on the side of a volcano and
we were looking for these little tiny
angelfish that you only find on that
volcano off off Maui and I kept seeing a
reflection of a boat and in my glasses
as though in my mask because though
there was water in there so flipped at
my mask and cleared it and I kept seeing
it
so I turned around and there was a huge
boat like object about 20 feet below the
boat and I suddenly realized it's a
whale shark never seen a whale shark in
fact we've been talking on the way out
with the boat captain who'd never seen a
whale shark either and so I started to
swim towards it and the dive master came
along as decided to come along and then
later everybody else decided to come
along and we went up to this whale shark
and it was brown and gray with white
spots and it's had it felt a little bit
like sandpaper and it had these big
flutings like on the bottom of a butter
speedboats on it and then everybody else
started to come up and so it turned a
way to go out to sea so I decided to put
my hands around it's still sort of thing
because it was either Now or Never
and so I'm there and the thing starts to
take off out to sea and the water is
rushing into my face and I rely on my
heart's beating really fast and I'm
sucking down my hair and I realized I
have no idea how much time has gone fast
it could have been 30 seconds it could
have been 5 10 minutes have no idea what
the speed of this thing is doing all I
can see is blue open water in front of
me and hurtling like this and so ah so I
have to let go because I don't know how
far I have to swim back to the boats or
the volcano and
yeah I let it go and it's tail came
through slap to my leg and it stung and
I wasn't quite sure if it broke my leg
or nothing wrong or maybe sliced it open
or anything so I kind of made my way up
and I couldn't see any brown cloud
around me so I assumed my leg wasn't
broken or damaged and I get up to the
surface and I almost used all my arrow
because I'm sucking it down so fast and
I'm about 20 feet from the bug so I
could held on for life 10 more minutes
then instead I'm like 20 feet from the
boat so I was really upset and I got
back onto the boat and I look like her I
didn't know how to use my air very well
because everybody else was still down
and I came up and the boat master said
so do you did you to give say anything
interesting I said yeah well sharp and
she said oh yeah uh-huh and then this
other person came up who was a newbie
and so she came up and sat down and
asked so what do you think of that and
she said what do you mean I said the
whale shark and she said oh you mean
that big fish
yeah a big fish and sounds like okay
doesn't matter I saw a whale shark okay
whatever anybody else says and that but
a boat master turn around sick there
really was a whale shark I said yes
right I turned around you I said in fact
you can just see it just there and
before it the diver mad boat masters
never supposed to leave the boat but
before I knew it she grabbed the mask
and fins and was in the water swimming
over to the whale shark and she got
close but she didn't get that close and
so that's my story when we got back to
shore later that night there was
somebody there was this rumor going
around that somebody had been had
touched and actually ridden a whale
shark today and that's terrible I should
never
I cannot believe anybody would do no you
only get one chance sometimes I'm gonna
tell you something a little personal it
happened today actually I got I got my
money stole from and I'm pretty sure I
beat my friend's ass well obviously we
are no longer friends but we were doing
a lot of uber and stuff this week for
this trip I just came to San Diego from
Texas shout-out to Dallas and she was
leavin for her to like she had an early
flight and I owed her some money but I
told her I'd send it to her when I woke
up I was sleep and instead of instead of
allowing me to send her the money she
stole it out of my wallet so I'm not
sure if it's hands or not
I don't know if I should forgive her
knock right now it just happened so I'm
all angry about it right so my story is
when I was learning to be a pilot so I
was flying this little airplane a Cessna
172 so it has room for just four people
and I was all by myself and I was flying
from one town in Minnesota and then I
had to go to the next town Raj Redwood
Falls and it was pretty much just
farmland in between the two and this was
before GPS and so as I was flying I was
supposed to watch my math and find out
when there's certain spots on my map
that I was crossing I forgot to do that
and all of a sudden I realized I had no
idea where I was I was so lost and I did
not want to ask for directions I could
have called and talked on the radio and
asked somebody where was I but I didn't
want to do that because that would be so
embarrassing so finally I kept lying and
I kept flying and I finally came up on a
tiny little town and I got really low
and I buzzed their water towers so I
could read the name on the water tower
and lo and behold I was right where I
was supposed to be I just had no idea
and so I managed to finally get to where
I was going and I landed and I I did end
up getting my pilot's license but I now
know I'm thankful that they put names on
water towers in case the pilot ever gets
lost
I wrestled in high school for war in
high school and I remember one time in
the match
I got head-butted right on the nose like
and it just broke and it was really just
like painful and blood was everywhere
just like all over my chest I couldn't
breathe and I tried breathing out and
like blood would blood were just like
spelling for me oh but my coach is a
very very very tough kind of coach what
he did he sent me to the cheerleaders to
get tampons from them and so there I am
I go to them with a bloody nose and ask
him for tampons they happen to have some
like here he's like just stick those in
your nose and get back in there so I
finished the match with two tampons in
my nose and the strings dangling and
then afterwards I went to go get a fix
you keep still kind of see it's a little
like my deviated but I don't know I
thought that was pretty funny
I was really interesting and I always
have this term life
one day I was walking through the park
and a girl like camera came up to me
asked to ask me some questions and film
me it said okay what's up guys my name
is Mariah and I'm the owner of this
channel I'm also the person behind the
camera and I thought I'd take a minute
to thank all the subscribers I gained so
far and maybe ask new years to hit the
subscribe button if you liked this
episode or if you're fans with my
channel in general don't need a lot
thank you